zwei wochen nach einem foto das wir
ihnen jetzt zeigen sind drei
freunde tot es geht um einen wirklich
furchtbaren unfall wir wollen uns mal
das foto anschauen es ist die tragische
geschichte aus haffkrug in schleswig
holstein und ich habe es eben gesagt
kurz nach der aufnahme dieses fotos sind
drei freunde tot es ist eine geschichte
vor der alle eltern angst haben wenn
ihre kinder feiern gehen und weil sie in
ländlichen regionen leben mit dem auto
unterwegs sind
wir blicken in die strahlenden gesichter
von glücklichen jungen menschen sie
hatten das ganze leben noch vor sich
jetzt sind drei jugendliche tod ein
vierter liegt lebensgefährlich verletzt
in einer klinik der vergangenen
donnerstag ist ein wolkenloser tag an
der ostsee die freunde ivan 19 17
lorenzo 18 und dennis 17 grillen nach
mitternacht steigen die vier in den audi
von ivan um 51 verliert der fahrer auf
der b 76 bei haffkrug an der ostsee in
schleswig holstein die kontrolle der
audi dreht sich mehrfach prallt gegen
einen baum
beteiligt war ein fahrzeug nach ersten
ermittlungen kam dieses in einer
langgezogenen rechtskurve
aufgrund
überhöhter geschwindigkeit nach links
von der fahrbahn ab und prallte dort
gegen einen baum der pkw wurde durch die
wucht des aufpralls in zwei teile
zerrissen und
das trümmerfeld erstreckte sich über
zirka 300 meter
ein lkw fahrer entdeckte das wrack wird
die 110 als die ersten einsatzkräfte vor
ort sind lebt lorenzo noch doch sowie
dennis und ivan sind tot retter bringen
den einzigen überlebenden ins
uniklinikum lebensgefahr die polizei
ermittelt wo wollten die freunde in der
nacht hin warum verlor der fahrer die
kontrolle warum war zu schnell unterwegs
war er alkoholisiert
auch am tag nach dem unfall immer noch
ein bild des grauens selbst die
einsatzkräfte sind erschüttert die drei
freunde sie hinterlassen eine riesige
lücke junge menschen in ihrem alter
haben das mit abstand höchste
unfallrisiko im straßenverkehr zu
verunglücken doppelt so häufig wie
ältere erfahrenere verkehrsteilnehmer
2022 kamen bei verkehrsunfällen mit
autos 175 junge erwachsene als fahrer
oder mitfahrer ums leben hinter jedem
getöteten steckt ein schicksal wie jetzt
dass der drei freunde
[Musik]